[Music]
the current virus pandemic spreading
across the country now further
disrupting daily life nearly 3,000 cases
now reported in 49 states and Washington
DC a total of 57 deaths with the
majority in hard-hit Washington State
this is the House overwhelmingly passed
bipartisan emergency legislation to
fight this pandemic after getting
president Trump's backing it goes now to
the Senate
my first guest says we can overcome this
House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy of
California congressman it's good to see
this morning thanks very much for
joining us thanks for having me back
Maria tell me about the bill that really
went so late on Friday night what it has
in it why is it important well we went
late because the original bill that
speaker Pelosi put was just not workable
and as I said on Thursday we should take
a deep breath not leave Congress take
the next 24 and 48 hours and fix it and
actually come together take the parts
that divide us unless unite for the
American public what it does is three
main things and make sure everybody has
the ability to get a test if they need
it it allows for sick leave if you are
sick or if you're caring for a loved one
it makes sure the VA in the end the
Department of Defense has the resources
needed to care for those veterans I had
a real concern when it what it did to
small business that were some real
changes inside the bill and that's why
it came late I wanted flexibility for
those small business especially under 50
we have to make sure if you're going to
mandate small business to provide this
leave how can they have the resources
the speaker had the social security
doing it would harm Social Security and
they couldn't get it up and running the
Secretary of Treasury will now advance
the money to small business for that
quarter to pay for that sick leave going
forward for this short time period
making sure that we have a timetable on
this that there is a sunset and also
Democrats had put in a number of
provisions that were just
philosophically wrong with anything to
do here they want to change the law and
have taxpayer pay for abortion we made
sure we took that out as well why don't
understand you had abortion in in in a
bill about carniverous yeah the things
you have to watch
especially when it doesn't go through
committee especially when there's a
crisis people will take their
philosophical beliefs and try to run
that through we have the Hyde Amendment
that we have voted on for decades I
wanted to make sure that provision was
in I wanted to also make sure there's
flexibility especially for those small
businesses 50 or under if this is a
hardship to them that they have the
option to get out and that was one of
the last provisions we got into the bill
I want to make sure people have jobs to
come back to let me ask you about this
article on the Federalist which is
complaining the title of the article is
why the Pelosi wuhan virus deal is a
near-total GOP surrender for blue-collar
entrepreneurs and they are zeroing in
and what you're talking about in terms
of small and mid-sized businesses and
they're saying that we're gonna see
layoffs once this is over from small and
mid-sized businesses they need anything
they can cling to to stay afloat and
delay further layoffs there's nothing
for them in this apparent deal nothing
for the blue-collar businessman this
country's middle class was founded on
even the fifty billion dollars that the
president previously announced for small
business are not only good for big
businesses who can guarantee it but it's
bad for smaller businesses you are
getting some pushback on this idea that
small and mid-sized businesses are
having to put out this big cost well if
they read the final version of the bill
they'd see the flexibility that the
secretary has the Secretary of Treasury
will actually advance the money ahead of
time so the small business will be able
to have the resources if they have
somebody on sick leave remember there's
a sunset time period and also remember
what we're dealing with here just as dr.
Fuji Cefalu she says we've got to get
through that peak peak can over overtake
the medical system you watch what the
World Health Organization has recently
said that Europe is the epicenter we
want to thank this president for the
action he took early stopping the
flights from China also stopping those
flights from Europe it is making America
safer so how do we manage all this going
forward if somebody is sick we want to
make sure they have testing we want to
make sure they're not at work providing
and making contamination to other
individuals so we've got to have that
sickly we know business is being hurt
there is no basketball going on there is
no March Madness
there's no hockey going on people are
quarantine in themselves which what we
need to do as we go through this so we
need action and that's why we gave that
flexibility in the advancement of money
remember America working together can
get through anything that we need and we
showed just that last Friday night that
we can what divides us can come together
for the American public and you watch
the action that this president take took
extraordinary and he's looking further
ahead from the oil industry filling the
spur because it's a lower oil price
helping the energy at the same time
helping America making sure no interest
rates on those who have student loans
we're taking every possible action but
this is a moment in time that we need to
come together and that's why Sun setting
it giving small businesses the resources
they need and help during this time we
will get through this together and we
will actually be stronger in the end
yeah I mean you make a good point this
is a moment in time that all hands are
on deck this is a moment in time that
everyone's worried about this pen Demick
now the World Health Organization is
calling it so why did it take so long to
get this done why were you at work at
1:00 a.m. on Friday night I mean what
why did Nancy Pelosi have so much delay
if this is such a if there's such
urgency well there's a number of reasons
of things going through but the reason
why it was late into the night I did not
want to see a bill jam because it did
not go through committee I wanted more
eyes on it I wanted that ability to walk
through every version there's it's going
go to the Senate I was working with
Senator McConnell the leader over in the
Senate on numerous things that I would
see that it could enhance even further
working with this president this
president has taken decisive active
action early to help help us in this
cause of where we're walking through
this bill adds to that at the same time
you want to have testing and I think
what the president has done with that
public-private partnership every
community either has a CVS or
all greens a target or a Walmart to be
able to open up their parking lots to
have this testing and have the new
version of testing going through
we have innovative companies here that
are going to help us you look at what
Gilead is going through with the therapy
for the treatment you look at Johnson &
Johnson and other companies to get as a
vaccine we want to work through this
together I remember the story about
President Kennedy when he challenged
this country to go to the moon a year
later he's walking through NASA
he's meeting those who worked there he
runs into an individual who's a Janet
and he asked them what's your job and he
says my job is to put a man on the moon
at this moment in time Republicans
Democrats and all Americans need to come
together and our job is to make sure we
get through this virus attack that did
not come from here and make sure we're
safe and we're going to take actions we
haven't taken before and we will come
out stronger just as we have before so
when we were on the phone this weekend
talking about this interview you talked
about this virus being sort of like an
ark it's going to get worse before it
gets better and then maybe it dies down
but do you expect that it comes back in
the fall well not sure we learn
something more every day about this
coronavirus but affluenza normally in
summertime dips down and can come back
in the fall what we need to have happen
here is as many in the NIH will tell you
you do not want to have something to
overrun as a big peak you want to you
want to level it out as the graphs would
show Italy right now is not did not have
that happen because their leadership did
not take the actions at President Trump
to them that's why the next four weeks
are so critical that's why this
determination of the actions that we are
making are smart in the long run we do
not want our health care system that's
why elective surgeries are being pushed
aside that's why we're preparing and
doing the public-private partnership
more testing the VA this is more
vulnerable for those who are older all
the information that we have the washing
of the hands and the others sure
everybody needs to be working together
and I think Congress showed that Friday
night let me ask you come before you go
we're going to talk about the economic
impact with Peter Navarro and and a lot
of people are expecting
I love what the president said the other
day about oil and buying new oil we're
gonna talk about that with Peter Navarro
as well but from your standpoint in
terms of getting to a vaccine what you
just said in terms of pharmaceutical
companies are you willing to make sure
that the rules and regulations around
the FDA in terms of getting a drug
through approval process or are dealt
with some leniency in terms of getting a
fast-track approval yes the president
has already taken actions on that as
well what's unique to here is we have
had some changes within the FDA in this
Trump administration to streamline to
make sure nothing from a bureaucratic
incidence is holding it up and we've got
a lot of smart companies out there
already working together remember when a
bola hit it was an American company that
got the vaccine we were able to use NIH
to make sure that containment happened
unfortunately when this crisis hit China
hid from it in November it came forward
President Trump asked to send our
scientists our doctors our very best
researchers there they were not allowed
to now it is a spread across the world
but the actions the president Trump has
taken has actually made us safer but
unfortunately now Europe is the
epicenter yeah and that's why the action
that he took on the flights coming
through that's why Americans need to
work together but it has to be a
public-private partnership and I will
tell you we have overcome things that
are bigger but the next four weeks or
where we need to be smart act together
and find a way that we will get through
that we will not have that peak but we
will measure this out at the end of the
day you and I will talk again on this
show and we'll talk about the ingenuity
of our companies that got a vaccine for
it and how we were prepared ahead of
time just like we did by increasing
funding to the NIH and CDC for the last
four years do you think do you think
that you're gonna need to the president
will need to mobilize the military to to
create hospital beds I know we've got a
lot of shortages including hospital beds
as these numbers spike are you gonna
need some is the president going to need
to mobilize the military for this well
the one thing that we could do there is
a bill by dr. Burgess that you bring in
the reserve medical in to help in that
instance you want to make sure you
check the other element inside this bill
I did not talk about we want to make
sure that we have more mass especially
for all those in the medical category of
the Syrians that they are protected yeah
but this bill allowed them to actually
produce millions of more the industrial
level version that can help those in the
medical industry and now they can sell
them to them so there's many different
elements of this bill that protects us
even further all right and these are the
plantings that we were taking
unfortunately we tried to get that in
supplemental but Democrats had said no
earlier congressman is good to have you
on the program this morning thanks very
much for your efforts Thank You Murray
we'll see you soon Minority Leader Kevin
McCarthy there